now one Muslim scholar has been urging
leaders to condemn all of this and even
went to Israel herself to see evidence
of these atrocities firsthand joining me
now live from Israel is Dr K Ahmed an
iwf senior fellow Dr Ahmed um thank you
for joining us now we're going to get
into what you're learning on the ground
in a moment but first your reaction to
see these protests in European
capitals it's utterly devastating uh
imagine the same Pro tests uh in
reaction to the atrocities Isis
committed to the yazidi people and the
Kurdish people um I understand the
politics related to Palestine but what
Hamas has perpetrated is a crime against
humanity we keep describing this
conflict using the language of
conventional
War genocide has been committed I have
witnessed the remnants of genocide in
the homes in which they were committed
in kabut be I have talked to survivors
that were uh defending uh themselves
their neighbors from multiple terrorists
and I'm and tragically also from
hundreds if not thousands of civilians
as well from Gaza that came repeatedly
I've met with children that were
terrorized by this today I was in a 43
minute movie shown privately to the
international press at cam Camp G
um here in Israel and the atrocities are
uh Beyond imagination and I have met
with child Isis soldiers and I have met
with child Taliban soldiers and I've
seen all those atrocities too and so any
legitimacy to Hamas is fundamentally
immoral irrespective of anyone's
politics or nationality there is an
urgent need for Muslim leaders that
means president CeCe King Abdullah of
Jordan Crown Prince Muhammad bin Salman
of Saudi Arabia to see the footage to
see the atrocity to see the
dehumanization of manom child elderly
disabled infant in the name of Hamas Who
Dares use my religion to to prosecute
its genocide we are living through a
realtime genocide we have more data on
this Israel is beginning to collect data
on these crimes of humanity as Israel
prepares for a
rightful action against Hamas which is
to defeat it which I believe will
require a ground Invasion and which
Israel is morally authentic morally
authorized to do as a rightful member of
the International Community I do not
want to see more civilian casualties the
Arab world must help with the
humanitarian Corridor that's the Muslim
world that's the Muslim majority world
has to take action but we cannot not
tolerate any Civilized Nation living
next to this monster which is Isis on
steroids financed with millions of
dollars the amount of ammunitions they
brought in the barbarity the
psychological warfare there has not been
anything like this and it must be
stopped but again we got to go but the
fact that Biden is hinting with his
shoot from the hip commentary today that
if they release the hostages then we'll
push for ceasefire and all to me that's
just rewarding them for everything they
did Dr ammed staggering tonight thank
you hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere
else